in the time it takes to bowl and over
for rubbish trucks worth of plastic is
dumped in the ocean that's frightening
enough to get to England crickets tiles
behind a campaign to make the Kia Oval a
plastic free venue by 2050 there's a
chance that we more plastic and plastic
in the ocean and fish which is really
scary for our world isn't it so it's one
of those things that we need to start
making a change now and this is an
amazing initiative I mean sports grounds
do waste a lot of plastic and something
for the Cure able to be able to get
involved is wonderful where there are
people there is waste major events like
Glastonbury Festival generate tons of
rubbish much of it is single-use plastic
and plastic bottles here at The Oval
25,000 people pack these stands during a
busy Test match it takes hours to clean
up after them and less than 50% of a
thrown away plastic bottles are
recyclable they can end up on beaches
and in season oceans across the world
every year 8 million tons of fresh
plastic has added to our waters it never
decomposes last year the Kea ovale
introduced eco-friendly plastic glasses
and this week it'll be handing out
20,000 free reusable water bottles it's
hoped that even a small change in
behavior by the thousands of spectators
that will fill these seats will go a
long way to helping cut down on plastic
waste this is one of 20 new water
fountains around the ground although for
now you'll still be able to buy bottles
of water here it's hoped that this is
the start of the ovals plastic free
future we're hoping just to be able to
inform and educate and allow people to
make their own decisions and I think
when we're successful in doing that it
will take a couple of years we'll see
real and meaningful change
it's small steps for now but organizers
here at the oval say it'll take just
three years until plastic use is well
and truly over Katarina pototsky Sky
News at the oval